All right.
We have come to the final unit here in
health class sexual education.
Now, this is mature subject matter, and I
expect you all to handle it with maturity,
like the young adults you are becoming.
I'm scared, Teddy. What if he shows us a
diagram of a vagina and I get a boner?
You're getting a boner before this class
ends, buddy. The sooner you wrap your head
around that, the better.
Sexual intercourse is a physical expression
of love and affection that is perfectly
natural and often deadly.
Sexually transmitted diseases include
gonorrhea, HIV, herpes, chlamydia, HPV,
hepatitis A through C.
Jfk blown away.
What else do I have to say?
We didn't start the fire.
Ted,
knock it off. See, this is exactly what I'm
talking about. To avoid sexually transmitted
disease, it is important to practice safe
sex. Now, who can tell me what the safest
sex of all is?
No one?
Masturbation.
If you're going to assign homework.
Johnny already did it this morning.
Shut the f***
up, dude.
He's doing extra
credit. Be quiet.
Stop it! Oh.
You keep that up. You're headed for
detention, mister. Now, why is it important
to practice safe sex?
Well, it all begins with biology.
Oh, here we go.
Let's start with the female reproductive
system.
Oh, no.
Holy sh*t. That's fast, even for you.
Well, I'm glad that's over, huh?
I know that was like sex ed for babies.
What? I mean, you're really gonna talk about
masturbation and leave out edging?
Seriously?
You didn't even talk about how massaging the
prostate increases orgasm intensity.
Did ya see how when I brought up
rimming, he flipped to the glossary.
Wait, you two, you two have had sex?
No, I'm felching my own jizz.
Duah were 16.
When? With who?
A few weeks ago. With each other.
We didn't want to be the last ones in school
to lose our virginity.
Oh, yeah? No, right.
Of course. How how lame would that be?
Right? Wow.
I didn't even know you two guys were dating.
Andrew, I thought you were gay.
I don't know, might be.
I just know I'm not a f***ing loser.
You're so confident, I love it.
Let's go to the computer room.
We can do it on the Oregon Trail.
Holy sh*t, Teddy. Do you know what this
means? I'm the last virgin in school.
What about
Ben Cronus?
No. He slept with his math teacher.
That's why she got fired.
I thought she got fired for giving him angel
dust.
Yeah, Teddy, I think that was the trade.
Oh. Oh, wow. Oh, yeah.
Well, then that's a mess anyway.
Dude, this is serious.
I need to hurry up and have sex with
somebody before people find out.
And I'm humiliated.
You're right.
We got to find a buyer.
Fresh penis. Get your fresh penis here.
Jesus Christ, this penis used to belong to a
little old lady who only f***ed it on
Sundays. Still has that new penis smell.
Will you shut up? All right, I'm just trying
to help.